[Music]
tonight is for Kobe lizzo kicked off her
first ever Grammys performance with a
tribute to Bryant who died in a
helicopter crash Sunday morning before
delivering an electrifying medley of her
songs in the house that Kobe built LA's
Staples Center
[Applause]
the breakthrough artists belted out cuz
I love you while wearing a stunning
custom black crystal fan color ball gown
by Christian Siriano next ELISA stick
corset for her performance of truth hurt
which was complete with ballerinas and
of course her iconic flute
everything Coby the Jonas Brothers
rocking metallic and black suits debuted
their unreleased song five more minutes
before making their way to the main
stage Kevin sneaking in a kiss for his
wife along the way
[Music]
the job rose up to the energy performing
their new single what a man got to do
complete with dancers and trumpets and
it turns out Nick had food in his teeth
during the entire thing he took to
Twitter shortly after their performance
writings at least you all know I eat my
greens they got a round of applause
backstage then there's Camilla Kibeho
singing first man while childhood videos
of her with her father plead in the
background which will bring you to tears
[Music]
but still
[Music]
and if that didn't get you all choked up
Feliz pops wiping away tears and coming
onstage to hug her at the end will
destroy you in the best way possible
[Music]